master oogway
master uh he says a couple things i'd
like to uh bring up with you
so one as part of a longer quote
recommends
that you should find a battle worth
fighting
we've talked about several battles just
now
what is the battle worth fighting for
for eric weinstein
in the next few months in the next year
there's only one
oh it's the moses it's the moses thing
it's time to go it's time to leave this
place is over to get off the planet
i yeah i i freak people out when i say
that but
like look at your world you just got
introduced
to the problem of a virus wait wait till
it's fusion devices and you understand
what it means to have
one interconnected planet with no
uncorrelated
experiments happening anywhere else you
know
so do you see the foray
your work in physics and maybe like the
echoes of it
in uh ship elon everybody who has a
possible plan to avoid what is coming if
we don't have one
should work on the plan that he she
thinks best right so elon wants to do
rockets
people misinterpret me i meta eric
says i don't think that's a smart plan
regular eric says
all people who have hope should do
that thing yeah at least it's mars man
at least it's the moon and mars and
maybe titan and whatever and i don't
think it'll work and it doesn't make
sense and it looks silly but that's
exactly the kind of fight worth fighting
but it's
it's the kind of it's for the same
reason that i went on brett's unity 2020
thing when i didn't think it had a hope
in hell and people
you know are making fun of it we got to
do things that make that
make us feel dumb and silly and childish
that possibly have a hope of working
okay so everybody should do something my
version of this
i'm the most hopeful about because i
wouldn't have chosen to do if i thought
that daniel schmochtenberger's wisdom
project
was a better hope i'd do that
it's more down to earth in a certain way
i just think that it's more probable
look we got from
powered flight with the wright brothers
and wind tunnels
to sending back images from the surface
of titan via huygens cassini
in less than a century okay what we can
do if we can
change the laws of physics is something
we
can't even conceive of it may be that it
buys us
nothing and at least we'll
we will know why we died on this planet
you